when I was three years old I was trans
racially adopted from South Korea by
white family in Salt Lake City Utah I
arrived in America with a mysterious
tattoo on my left forearm the tattoo was
so large and noticeable that my adoptive
parents had it surgically removed right
away they were worried that other kids
would make fun of it today there's only
a light scar where the tattoo once was
so I've redrawn it in permanent marker
so you can see what it looked like
Korean adoption records in 1976 were
notoriously incomplete I didn't have any
information about my background or my
birth family I didn't even know if my
name or birthdate were real or if they
were assigned and no one knew what my
tattoo meant transracial adoption is
where a child from one race or ethnicity
is adopted by parents from a different
race or ethnicity in my generation
children who are adopted from Korea were
assimilated into the culture of their
adoptive parents so I was raised as if I
were white growing up occasionally my
family would eat at a Korean restaurant
or we go to the Asian festival but I did
not identify with being Asian looking
back now having my tattoo removed is
symbolic of losing a connection with my
Korean ethnicity and culture and I am
NOT alone since the 1950s almost 200,000
Korean children have been adopted all
over the world a growing body of
research shows that children experienced
trauma when they're separated from their
families of origin my story includes
such childhood trauma I recently found
out that my birth mother left my family
shortly after I was born when I was 2
years old my birth father became injured
and could not provide for my brothers
and me
and so my two older brothers and I were
sent to children welfare services and
there someone decided because I was
younger that I was more adoptable and so
I was sent to a separate orphanage
separated from my brothers who cared for
me my adoption records say that I
wouldn't play with any of the other
children at the orphanage and now I know
why my adoption photos show the picture
of a frightened malnourished little girl
just imagine my culture shock a short
and lonely nine months later as I
arrived in America where everything was
different the people the buildings the
food and the clothing as a
three-year-old child I quickly figured
out that no one spoke the Korean
language that I spoke and so I stopped
speaking altogether for six months and
when I started speaking again it was in
full English one of the first phrases i
said as my parents showed me my
orphanage photos was sarah sad children
who are adopted often put up emotional
walls to protect themselves from being
hurt again I certainly did this and like
many translationally adopted children
there were many moments growing up where
I wish that I was white like the other
kids around me other kids made fun of my
eyes and nose now the 80 styles are
particularly brutal to me with glasses
that didn't fit well hair styles that
looked ridiculous on me this narrative
of adoption might be uncomfortable for
you to hear the narrative that we
usually hear is that of a new parent
who's eagerly awaiting a child that
they've been wanting for so long the
parents story is told with love joy and
excitement and as they bring a newly
adopted child into their home family and
friends celebrate and congratulate the
parents
their wonderful decision to adopt my
parents adoption story was like a
beautiful blanket that kept me warm but
after a while it felt like the focus is
more on the blanket covering me in my
point of view entirely
I couldn't emotionally breathe my
parents would say things to me like I
fell in love with you the first time I
saw your photo my heart broke they loved
me
I know that and I was wanted but I wish
that the only birth story I had wasn't
so sad so humanitarian I would often
confuse love with gratitude especially
when other people would say things to me
like you're so lucky to be adopted to
America or your parents are such angels
to adopt you to a child it felt like
these comments were constant reminders
to be grateful to my parents charity I
resented that I couldn't tell these
adults I don't like being reminded all
the time that I'm adopted I just want to
be a normal kid and maybe even be
ungrateful once in a while but I learned
to smile without really smiling and as I
grew older I wanted to be able to say
Sarah is still sad but I buried my
feelings and it wasn't until later in
life that I realized I'd never really
grieved my own adoption while many of us
understand that adopting a child from a
different race culture or country is
never simple
we rarely acknowledge the complex
emotions that children who are adopted
can experience some children experience
feelings of loss feelings of rejection
grief shame guilt challenges with
identity difficulty with intimacy and
control issues just ask my kids children
who are adopted can still love their
adoptive parents at the same time as
experience
these complex emotions and many of us
wonder if we had had safe emotional
spaces to own our own stories when we
were younger would we still be
struggling to come to terms with
adoption as adults where do we find the
emotional oxygen to own our own stories
since the late 1990s and early 2000s
researchers like dr. Richard Lee have
focused on different parenting
techniques for transracial adoption the
hope is to help children and their
adoptive parents but our adapt to their
unique racial and ethnic circumstances
there's more enculturation encouraged
that exposes children to the people
places languages and culture of their
birth families some parents focus on
racial implication to specifically work
with their children on the racism and
discrimination that they will experience
outside of the home and some parents
allow children to choose as they get
older the level of exposure to the
culture of their birth families now we
might look at these signs of progress
and think we've got it all figured out
when it comes to transracial adoption
but Korean adoptees were the first
massive wave of international adoptions
almost 30 years earlier than most other
countries and so there are entire
generations of Korean adoptees from
children all the way to adults in their
70s dealing with the impact of their
assimilation and there have only been a
handful of studies that follow
transracial adoptees over a lifetime I
know that people around me could not
understand my adoption grief Rachel Ross
dad another Korean adoptee expressed
what I was feeling when she said loss is
especially confusing to measure when it
appears as if I haven't lost anything at
all it's not missing like an organ it's
missing like wherever dreams go when you
blink awake into the morning light every
year hundreds of South Korean adoptees
search for their birth families and
Korean age
sieze report that less than 15% are
successful last year I found my Korean
birth family in just three months I
posted a photo of my redrawn tattoo on
social media which Korean groups
generously shared and a friend of my
brother saw the photo and he knew
instantly with the tattoo meant when my
father decided to send us to children
welfare services he was worried that we
would be separated and even adopted into
foreign countries and so he took the
unusual step to place a large tattoo on
each of our arms and on his own so that
we could find each other someday and he
tried searching for me and he was right
the tattoo did eventually lead me to
find the family that I had lost
unfortunately he passed away nine years
before he could see his children
reunited but last year I traveled to
Korea to meet my two older brothers my
aunt and uncle and I learned a lot of
new things about myself including my
real birth date which actually makes me
7 months older this middle aged woman
did not love hearing that she is older
and that explains all those gifted in
talented classes I had in school but the
most important thing that I learned was
that I had a loving family in Korea who
remembered me as a little baby and had
never forgotten me it wasn't abandoned
like my adoption records said I was
wanted
it's time to reframe our views on
adoption a healthy adoption ecosystem is
one in which children adoptive families
and birth families each own their unique
stories when these narratives are placed
side by side it creates better empathy
and policies for the lives that adoption
impacts here are two things that adults
can do to better protect adopted
children stories
first give children's safe emotional
spaces to express their emotions both
positive and negative phrases such as
tell me more what do you wish for and
those feelings are normal are ways that
parents can grant emotional oxygen to
their children
second validate a child's adoption story
children may express emotions that may
feel hurtful or worry an adoptive parent
as a parent work to hold and manage your
fears separately from your child always
acknowledge your child's story as valid
and important now it's natural to want
to protect children from experiencing
pain but my tattoo is a poignant
reminder that every adoption starts with
loss and every child is affected
differently children who are adopted can
live full rich lives as we accept and
build upon this unique set of cards that
we were dealt and as you listen to our
narratives with empathy you will hear
other things as well
childlike curiosity grace resilience
courage love and yes even gratitude
thank you
[Applause]